113 questions about evolution
with john perry evolutionary question
number 18
did humans evolve directly from
neanderthals
when we look around in the fossil record
neanderthals are
you know they're held up as the closest
relatives to humans you hear that quite
a bit that you know our ancestors were
neanderthals
it's not super accurate to say that
though because
we can't tell for sure by looking at
neanderthals that we actually evolved
from them in fact we're actually quite
certain that we did not evolve directly
from them
we actually now have genetic evidence
where we can sequence the dna of
neanderthals and humans
and it looks like instead of evolving
from them they were a sister clade to us
and that there were some europeans that
actually intermixed with them so
interbred with them so europeans do have
a little bit of
neanderthal dna in them and other
human groups other human populations do
not we all share a lot of dna with
neanderthals from our common ancestor
but neanderthals evolved then a separate
pathway that humans were evolving
and some of those unique neanderthal
traits
did end up in europeans through
cross breeding but i actually talked
quite a bit about how this works how it
is that we determine who our
ancestors are when we're looking at
fossils and what the what the
limitations are
when we're looking at fossils recently
when i was interviewed
by jonathan guzman jonathan guzman
is he's got he's a he's a young guy he's
got a youtube channel where he talks
about evolution
and dinosaurs and paleontology and he
had me on there just to kind of talk
about
how do we know who's related to who in
the fossil record i just wanted to show
you this clip
because i want you to know that his
channel exists but also
it was just a good conversation we hit
on some some topics that are really
important there
including whether or not neanderthals
are our
direct ancestors so here i'm going to
give you just a short clip
of part of our conversation and then
down in the video description if you
want to see the whole conversation
you can click on that and see our entire
discussion it was a lot of fun
enjoy how do we develop theories on
origins
from fossils like how do how can we tell
who came from where and who's the cousin
of from the fossils
yeah that that can get really tricky
yeah
uh first off if you look at most
textbooks
that so there's kind of a misconception
uh
especially when people are first
starting to study evolution that when we
find a fossil
you know like a neanderthal for example
that that is the ancestor of modern
humans
it's not actually how it works if you
look at textbooks you'll see that
you'll have like modern humans here
you'll have neanderthals here
then you'll have lines that go down and
connect
to what we would say is the hypothetical
common ancestor between the two
and the reason that we do that is it you
can never just
tell by looking at a specimen if it was
the actual ancestor
of a different specimen or of a modern
animal
and there's a there's a kind of thought
experiment
like imagine that you don't know who
your grandparents are
or any of your extended family and
somehow someone comes up to you and says
hey i'm your cousin we're gonna have a
family reunion
come hang out and you believe him and
you go there and you find a guy who's
old enough to be your grandpa
yeah well obviously he might not be your
grandpa right he might be your grandpa's
brother
or cousin or something so we can't ever
tell
for sure just by looking you know even
if even if this guy looks kind of like
you
and he's the right age we can't say for
sure that that is the
the ancestor and the same as with
apostles
the fossil looks right and is the right
age
it doesn't tell us that it's definitely
the ancestor
so like archaeopteryx is considered one
you know the earliest bird
but it's very likely
in fact that you know his lineage that
his it's a whole species their lineage
was a dead end
and that the common ancestor with modern
birds was back further in time
and split off so archaeopteryx is a good
example of an early bird
but it's not he's not you can never say
with certainty that it is
the ancestor of modern birds yes so it's
yeah so i think it's uh i think there's
actually a misconception
for a lot of people that think like oh
well archaeopteryx
is the ancestor of all modern birds
you know some people will make the
argument like
oh archaeopteryx is the ancestor of all
modern birds
therefore if we find modern birds before
archaeopteryx then archaeopteryx
cannot be a missing link or whatever
right um
but yeah like you said i think that
there are i i think i do remember seeing
a
phylogeny tree in one in a paper that i
was reading um
that has like uh archaeopteryx in it i
think all of them have like them and
archaeopteryx in a dead end like
their branch just splits off but they
share a common ancestor with
the consignateds which you know and
and uh eventually evolve into sinusoidal
you know consequences itself and whatnot
um yeah so i think there's
we actually always assume that a fossil
is as fossil species
is a dead end because it's just more
likely that
uh we found the dead end and we found
the actual literal ancestor of a modern
species because
because there's always this branching
and splitting that happens constantly
and i mean just if you just do the math
you'll find that it's
it's most likely that um
the species we've found is
it's just just a group that evolved from
a common ancestor to the main group
that doesn't mean that they can't tell
us about how things evolve because
you can see like in archaeopteryx it's a
very primitive flyer it's got three
fingers in its hand
that are that are independent still the
the flight feathers coming off the
middle finger
it's got a it's got the pointer finger
the middle finger
and the ring finger we see that modern
birds have this
but these three fingers are fused
together and oh it's only the top finger
that can move a little bit
it's got the alula on it which is a
little um
part of the the wing that sticks out
when they're trying to slow down
yeah and the other two fingers are
completely fused together in modern
birds
and they usually don't have claws on all
of their fingers archaeopteryx had claws
and all of them
we can see how uh these
forms evolved uh even though we can
never have absolute certainty that we're
looking at
an actual ancestor we're
we're looking at uh uh probably a sister
lineage to the actual ancestor
okay so um yeah i think that was
needed to say i think you needed to say
that because
there is actually a like a lot like
i was reading uh an article from the
creation ministries international
uh yesterday and i'm actually doing a
response like article to it
um but it's written by jonathan sarfati
and
brian thomas a spoiler alert
so there you have it my conversation
with jonathan guzman just
just a little taste of that conversation
if you want to see the whole thing there
is a link
down in the video description next
question
you